They'll beat a
tattoo a quarter to two
with a rat a tat tat
a tat tat a to too.
And the dragons will come when
they sound the drum in a minute
or two til two today, in
a minute or two til two.
[JAZZ MUSIC]
Hi.
Welcome to my class.
A voice-over booth can get
a little claustrophobic.
So how about we do this?
What better way to
learn about voice
acting than from an
animated character?
I'm going to tell you a little
story about a girl from Ohio.
The girl got a job
at a radio station
where she saw that you could
make a living with your voice.
So she worked her way up
and eventually did voices
for hit cartoons.
It took me getting
cast on "The Simpsons"
that I realized that I excelled
in doing quirky tomboys.
All right!
In this class, I'll teach you
everything about voice acting--
how to develop your characters.
This is just a little character
that I can use as our example.
One of the things
that you can do
is to change the pitch
of your character.
I can make him a little
bit lower like this.
Or I can lift him way
up high like this.
Performance tips and how to
start out in the industry.
Nobody knows what you look like.
They don't know how old you are.
They don't know
anything about you.
It's just your voice.
So anybody can do it.
And I'll demonstrate how
I bring animation to life
by voicing several original
characters from a show we
made called "No Effort Girl."
I didn't ask to be born
with super strength, X-ray
vision, and the ability to fly.
Ugh.
You'll learn how to distinguish
your characters so they
take on a life of their own.
So let's get started.
I'm Nancy Cartwright,
and this is my--
Wait, what are you doing?
I'm doing the MasterClass line.
But I'm the real Nancy.
I'll do it.
I'm Nancy Cartwright.
And this is my MasterClass.
[JAZZ MUSIC]